All right.  So, in this particular video, we do
one thing.  We set up our
cloud account.  Ok?  So, inside that we have to
add some credits.  We
will create our API key.  And let's have a hello world
program running.  So, with that let's
start with the video.  So, here you have to go to
platform.com.
So, this is the platform.  You can see that is
platform.com
and above all you have to sign up for free.
And then you have to add some credits.  Look
friend, nothing is free in the world of AI.
Even your first API call is
going to be paid.  So you have to get some
credits and you can see that I have $5 worth of
credits.  So you can also just
add $5 and $10 and there is no limit above this.
It's not something like you know
it will be over in just a month.   It's not like that.
This is based on your usage.
So, the more you use it, the more it will be
used.  And I feel that through this course
$5 is more than enough.  So make sure that you
click here to add funds and you
can just add $5 to your account.  And
for this particular series, I also
added $5 here.  So this is my balance
here.  Ok?  Then once you have added your
balance once you have some credits here.  Then what
you have to do is if we go down here.
So what you're going to see is
you're going to see this manage.  Ok?  So let
me just show you here.  So here I have
manage.  And inside Manage, I have
API Keys here.  Because I have to
create an API key here.  And this API key
will be used to interact with my account.
Ok?  Now here if you look at Agent SDK
and you scroll down and you go into this
quick start.  So here you
will see how to do a quick start.  So
here we will use a TypeScript.
But you can use all the knowledge inside Python also.
Because all these code
snippets and these Agent SD ones are
also available for Python.  So let's go
inside Quick Start.  And if I just
scroll down scroll down and I
will use TypeScript here.  So this is the
package that we need to install.  Ok?
So let's do one thing here.  Let's copy this command.
So I've
created a very empty project here.  So
you can see this is empty code.  So here the
first command that we will run is
npm in of course.  Ok?  npm in
enter enter enter.  So we enter all these things.
I could have done a lot of things but that's
okay.  A type here we will do the
module.  Ok?  Because I
want to use module js.  And once this all
setup is done.  And then we paste the command here.
That is npm install
@anthropic huffn ai klud agent sdk
Pretty big name right?  So you can see that our
particular agent SDK has also been
installed.  Now maybe when you are
installing this your version might be different because
these things update very quickly.
But make sure you are on something like
0.3 and something like that.  But that's okay,
meaning the concepts are always
transferable.  Ok?  So this is what we have done.
What do we have to do with it?  We need to
create an environment variable.  Ok?
So, let's just create a dot env file
and inside of it you have to create an
environment name, an environment variable
anthropoic underscore API underscore key.
You have to make it with this name.  This is the
exact name that you have to copy and paste.
And how do we set its value
?  We'll generate one of our API keys here
from the platform.com.
So, let's make one.  Let's Just Call
It As You Know Learning Series.  So you
can name it anything.  I will just call it as
learning series and we will
add it.  Now you don't use my key because while
you are watching this particular video
I will revoke this key.  So I'll
just copy this and I'll just paste it.
So what has happened to us?  This is our
secret key.  And
we can close this environment variable file.  Ok?
So what did we just do?  Now we have
set our ANB variables.
So we are all good.  And let's move ahead.
Now you can see what you can basically do is
you ah you can just you know
ignore these things.  So here's what I can do if I just go into
the overview and
write a simple hello world program.
Ok?  So we have to
import a function here.  That is a question.
Ok?  We need to import a query function here.
So let me go
with a little folder structure here.  So for
example this is our first class.  So let's
call this 001 Hello World.
And inside this I'm just going to
create a file that is known as main dots
file.  Ok?  So here you have to import
something from @anthropic SDK and
inside it you have a function known as query.  So this
query function is kind of your entry
point from which you start your agent SDK.
So what you can basically do is if
you see that you
can run the query function here simply.  And
inside the query you have to send a parameter
prompt.  What is PREP?  Whatever
user says that's a prop.  Ok?  So I can
send a prompt here.  For
example, let's say hey, how are you?  Ok my
name is Piyush Garg very simple.  So you see that's
what I did?  I
gave it a very simple print.
Gave a question.  Now this query is an
amazing thing.  What does she do?  It
sends a query to return these.
Sends a payload.  That is basically what I don't know if you know or
not.  In
JavaScript and in TypeScript you have something known as an
iterator pattern.
Ok?  What can you do in it?  You can
yield the output.  So it basically does the same thing.
So you can see what you
can do on top of this?  You can actually do an
iteration on the output.  So
what can I do on top of this?  I can loop over it.
So what will it give me?  She is
giving me a response from Lets.
Ok?  We put this on a response variable.
So this is a response.
What I can basically do is I can create
a main function.  async from let's.  Ok?
Because we should sync pay as here.
async function main and what I can
basically do is I can say for a wait okay a
wait
cost message a message will come of this
particular response what you are doing is you are
iterating whatever response you are getting
from the back end you are iterating on it
so this is a message and then
what you can do is you can just put a console.log as
saying response and then you
can put console.log here message.log so if
you want to have a type type you id
or then session id I can just print
message here.  So this is basically what we are doing here.
Ok?  And finally the main
function is called.  So this is my
very simple code that I got a response.
What did I do above the response?
I iterated over it and I
printed it out.  Let's run it once and
see.  What is the output?  So node.
What is the name of my file?  A folder
is named Zero One.  And inside that main and
enter.  Now you
cannot run TypeScript directly like this.  If you don't have
a newer version but you see I got an object.
Ok.  Let's do one thing.
We do not take this message outside.
Ok?  So let's take this message out here.
So that I can see clearly
what is basically happening and now run it.
So you can see this is basically what you get as an
output.  So a very big
response.  Ok?  So what have you got
?  Here's a response.  So, let's just
quickly expand it.  You
got the type.  You got the current working directory.
A session ID is received from the back end.  You
can see a lot of things are going on.  Ok
?  What is your response to this?  A lot of
things are going on.  If we scroll this further
, scroll.  So
you can see it loaded some plugins and so on.
Finally you have some type of rate limit
event.  While doing this, a typing
assistant came.  Ok?  And let's move ahead.  Ok
?  The assistant came again.  Then you have the
message.  Then you have some content.  So
what basically happened?  A complete loop was run.  You
might be thinking that Piyush, we just sent
him a simple message.  How are you?
But it is actually doing a lot of things.
And if you see carefully, this is basically
what you have as a final answer.  Can you see that
?  Hey Piyush, I am doing great.  Thanks
for asking a new line.  It's nice to
meet you.  I'm Klud.  Your AI assistant.
I am here to help you with coding,
answering questions, building stuff and all
that.  So, what happens here?  This is
actually an agent loop which we will
talk about in a video.  But, for now,
if you want to tidy it up,
what you can basically do is, you
can put that on top of a message.  If message
dot type equals to equals to
if that's basically an end.  Ok?  Ok.  So
you can see if it is a result.  So
what am I to do?  I just want to do a console
dot log of the final bot output.  So
what can I do here?  I can just say
message dot and what field can we pick above this
?  A, ours came here in the
result.  Right?  So most
probably I should have the result.  So, I can just say
message dot result.  Now you
might be thinking there is an error here because
it's a TypeScript thing.  You have to
put one more condition that is message dot a
you no stop reason.  A message dot stop a
sorry sub reason ah the sub type should be equals
to the success.  So if that is successful then only
you will get the result.  So now what you can
basically do is you can just remove this.  So
what are we doing now?  I
will print the result only when the
result is available to me.  Now if you run this
, you're going to actually see a
pretty good message now on the screen.  So
if I run this, you can see. Hey Piyush, I am
doing great.  Thanks for asking.  It's
nice to meet you.  I am your cloud AI
assistant build by Anthropic and all that
stuff.  You can see that.  So let me give you a
revision once.  That's basically
what happened here?  You imported the query.
Ok?  We fired the query.  Then
what did I do?  Look, when you run a query
, there's something called an agent loop,
which we'll talk about.  So
what this agent does is he analyzes a lot of things.
What is your intent?
What should I do?  What is the plan?  Because there was
no such intention in this case.  It was a very
simple prat.  So you could see that
he loaded a lot of things.  He was
loading some of Figma's MCB servers.  He was
loading some tools which you can
completely ignore.  So I said, friend, if
your message type is result and it is
a success, then just give me the final output.
Ignore everything else.  This is
basically what we have done and we got the
output.  So this is basically your hello
world in the AI ​​Agent SDK.  Ok?  So,
we have written a very simple hello world.
Now in the next video I will
explain to you what is the difference between an AI and an agent.
So that you come to know that
basically what is happening.  And
now let's see how much of that we used.
We ran this program twice.
So let's see 5.13 is also 5.13.
But let me just see my usage.  So if you will see
this usage, it will be updated in a while.
Ok?  So it is not updated in real time.  It will
update in a while.
So today it's May 29th.  So look now it has
not come in the update here.  Butt will come in a while.
So you have to wait for a little
while.  And if I try this again, I think if I will try it in
like four or five
minutes, then you will see today's usage also.
So let's just wait for a while.  Whenever it comes
I will show you the screenshot but it's not much.